えーと あの ついでに申し上げたいんですけど
なんか面白く まあこの頃観察すると
このかなり世界でいろんなところで平和運動というかね
平和のデモとかやってますね
で あの平和のデモをやってるんですけど
厳しい警備体制というかね
警察が動いて 厳しくそこで管理して
平和を守らなくちゃいけないということになるんで
そこはすごく面白いんですね
平和パレードをやると
平和を守るために 社会の秩序を守るために警察が動くと
これなんとことかと  平和のパレードだったら
これこそ楽しく みんなホッとするようなことでなければ
なんか論理的ではなくなくなるんですね
あれ どういうふうに解釈すればいいんでしょうかね
この平和パレードに行くね
日本でもたくさん起きてるし
いろんな国々でね まあ戦争反対運動っていうのはございまして
まあテレビを見てみると
結構厳しく管理するっていうかね
まあフランスかどうか
あの水をね 足している人々は
まあまあ脅したり追い返したりするとこまで行っちゃうんですね
だから平和はどこにあるのかっていうね
まあ問題になります   これどう解釈すればいいかっていうことはわかりませんだけど
一つはこの ただ面白いんですね
結局はこの矛盾的な人間のやり方っていうのはね
まあどちらか平和かなっていうことはわからないんですね
やっぱり人間っていうのは
まあ自分で何をやっているかっていうのが
やっぱりわかってないっていうことではないかなと
たとえ戦争反対 反対ということでデモをやっても
結局 まあ怒りやらね まあ誰かに対して怒りやら戦いやら攻撃やら心の中に抱いてしまうんですよ
うーん まあ例えばもうどんどん反米運動をエスカレートすると
まあそうすると また一つの国をまた悪人に回して
悪人に仕立てていて 反対することになっちゃうんですよ
だからアメリカがイラクを悪人に仕立てて戦争をすると
それは悪いと って思ったことところで
反米デモっていうものが出てきて
アメリカが悪いと悪人に仕立てると
どちらが平和ですかと
だから結局人間っていうのはどうったことないんですよ
何言ったっても 戦争は賛成やと言ったっても
戦争反対と言ったってもね
まあ大したことはない
結果は同じだと 世の中良くなるわけじゃないんだっていう悲観的な
まあ結論にしか結論しか出てこないんですね
そういうことで このまあ
この沈着冷静という心がね
これは仏教はすごい この徹底的にもう一度出てきて
まあ教えることで  それについて喋ってみようかなと
ですから そのまあまあ
日本語では書いてないんですけど
下この英語でね まあどういうウェルカムサプライズアタックストロンバイオレントイモーションズという
このあれは日本訳するために時間がなかったんですね
どう書けばいいんですかね
日本語には で 我々はどうやって乗り越えますか？と
この まあ突然の攻撃 あの
まあバイオレンスって何でしたっけ？暴力
いわゆる攻撃的な感情
まあ暴力的 攻撃的な 激しいですね
激しい感情の攻撃を それまだ突然攻撃なんですよ
激しい感情の突然の突然攻撃をどのように乗り越えればよろしいかということなんです
今日の話は だから この平和デモなんか見ると
まあ明らかに 突然どこでどんな感情が湧いてきて
人を困らせるということはわからないんですね
だからお釈迦様が言うのは
この突然我々にはこの
うん この凶暴なこの感情がね
激しい感情が湧いてくる
湧いてきて自分を攻撃する
自分攻撃されたらもう自分が何するか分からない
だからまあ大変な危険な結果になってしまうんですね
そういうわけで この沈着冷静な心を育てるっていうことが
まあ人間としてはまあ答えなんですよ
で まあ今日はあの サイド版も講演の半分しかないんですけど
まあはい 次に行きます
そこでこの一つの仏教
今日はパーリ語やらもう何もないんです
あの 一つの仏教の言葉
ウペッカーという言葉がございます
それを勉強してみましょうと
これはあの沈着冷静な心というのは
お釈迦様がウペッカーという言葉で説明しているんです
で まあまだ本当は訳してないんです
私は その時その時いろんな言葉入れちゃうんです
で まあ冷静ということかな
これ ウパという えーと
あの接尾語 何て言いますか
前に付ける言葉には  接頭語
接頭語  接頭語でウパという接頭語っていうのは落ち着いてフォーカス的にという意味になるんですね
イッカティっていうのは動詞なんです
それは見る 観察するという動詞なんです
だから意味 2つあります
目で見る意味もありますし
あの まあ心で見るという
考えて見るというね 意味でも使っている動詞はイッカティなんですね
そのウパとイッカティをあの
合わせてウペッカティという動詞が出てくるんです
それで訳はどう訳すればいいかと
さっぱりわからないんです
ウパは落ち着いてフォーカス的にイッカティは観察するという
それでウペッカティって何ですかと
ただそのまま並べたってじゃなくて
本当に何か適切な別な日本語の訳が出てこないとね
だから今はただのまあ意訳で言えば
まあフォーカス的に観察するという意味にはなります
それのそれにただの意味だけは下書いてます
同じ色にしてますから
遠くから見えるかどうか分かりませんですけど
落ち着いてフォーカス的に物事を観察することがウペッカーですと
はい それでなぜウペッカーが必要ですか？まあ
一つの例を前に言いましたけど
一応ここはいくつか例を並べてあるんです
知識 見方 偏見をなくす
トラブルにならない 問題は何でしたっけ？全体的に見える
解決方法を見つかる 後を引きずらない
後悔も自慢もせず済む
それから最後に執着しない生き方
心の自由 そういうものを得られるんですよ
まあ嫌ならもういっぺんか
嫌な こういう結果が嫌ならね
まあウペッカーも結構と思ってもいいんですけど
まあそういう結果っていうのはあり得るんです
だからなかなかの大変なことなんですよ
人間の問題に答え一言葉ではウペッカーなんです
それから仏教っていうのは知識人の教えであって
知恵に語ってあるんであって
感情に語っているわけじゃない
信仰に語っているわけじゃない
ですから もう最初から知識人の見方になるんです
では 次に行きます あのフリーズして直すところだったらね
で 一応知識人の見方というところはね
まああまり別に説明しなくてもわからない
わかると思いますけど
この世で無関心な人はいるが
ウペッカーの人はいません
であのウペッカーというのは冷静ということでとると
皆様方は誤解する可能性あります
冷静な人なんかそちらにもいるんじゃないかと
私の立場は全く違う そんな冷静な人はいませんよと
いるのは無関心なやつらだけやと
無関心な人はいるんですけど
ウペッカーの人はいません
で  2番目にも同じこと書いてありますからね
まあ鈍感 無関心 興味がないのような性格は
心の怠け現象です 無知の表れです
そういうわけで 我々の社会で
我々の世界で まあ無関心な人というのはいくらでもいますよ
あまり 例えば今の戦争について別に興味がない
私は落ち着いていますよと
まあ余計そういう関係ないことに手を出さない
もう考えもしないんだよという風に
この落ち着きかぶるんであって
本当に落ち着いているかと
これ違うんですよ だからそれが私が言うのは心の怠け現象
別に私はもう関心はありません
無関心だよと 世の中のことについても
まあ私もいろんな人々からあれこれ知ってるけど
あんまり知らないと いつでも首をひねっちゃうんですね
これ 何もものを知らないということはかっこいいことじゃないんですよ
明らかに怠け者なんですね
明らかに怠け 例えば新聞は読まないと言った途端
もう怠け者ということでしょうに
ですから この関心を持っていないということが
もう心の怠け現象で この怠けで生きていると
もう気楽になるところじゃないんですよ
もうどんどん無知になってしまうんです
無知になって正しい生活できるわけないでしょうに
だからよく覚えてください
世の中ではウペッカー
冷静な落ち着いた心の人っていうのはいません
いるのは怠け者も鈍感な人
だから誰かがなんかこの落ち着きかぶっちゃうと
まあ堂々と言ってください
まああんたもうただの怠け者ではないかと
それだけの答えなんです
とにかくウペッカーは生まれつきではありません
だから このウペッカーという冷静というこの性格が生まれつき付いてるものじゃない
生まれつき鈍感な人は生まれますよ
しかし 生まれつきウペッカーの人っていうのは生まれてこないんです
で ウペッカーは育てて得る能力です
だからウペッカーというものは
これから私たちは頑張って育てなくちゃいけないんです
知恵を育てるとウペッカーが現れる
ウペッカーを育てると知恵が現れる
そのなんて言いますか
相互関係 よく覚えておいてください
知恵がある人にウペッカー冷静さがある
冷静さがある人には知恵がある
どちらでもサイクルで回るんです
では 何を育てれば？何？どちらどちら
どちらを育ててもいいんです
ちょっとあの相互に行く矢印を書いておけばいいんですけど
まあもう今日朝それ作ったんですからね
まあそんなに遊ぶ余裕はなかったんです
で それであのウペッカーと
だから知識人の見方と書いたんだから
このウペッカーと まあこれからウペッカーという言葉できます
その方が専門用語だから
日本語ではっきりした言葉がないんで
私はいろんな言葉を使いますよ
冷静 平等 落ち着き これでまあもうこれ沈着という言葉とかね
だからどちらですかというと
私もわからなくなっちゃうんです
日本語で 例えば平等と冷静っていうのは
なんかえらい違うね 感覚的には
だから全部まとめたものだから
面倒くさいんですよ だからパーリ語のウペッカー
フォーカス的に観察するという
フォーカス的に観察するということは冷静ということでしょう
まあ平等っていうことでしょう
どこかに傾かないっていうことでしょう
誰かの味方を取るっていうことでもないでしょうしね
ですから まあそれで長いんだからね
フォーカス的に観察するということも長いんだから
ウペッカーっていうのは
ウペッカーって言葉をよく覚えておいてください
で 物事を観察するということは智慧なんですね
観察してわかると落ち着くんですよ
わからないと落ち着かないんですね
例えば 突然電車がね まあ止まってしまったら
ドア閉じたまんまで 1 分でもそのままいると
みんなイライライライラするんですよ
どうなってるんだ わからないんだから
それで車内放送でまあ信号停止とかね
なんとか言われたら問題解決してないんですよ
それで落ち着くんです
あるいは人身事故でしばらくお待ちくださいと
すると自分の問題は解決してないんですけど ３０
分でも４０ １時間でも
もう閉じ込められて電車の中でずっと待っている
その場合は ですから 知るということで落ち着きが来るんですよ
それで落ち着きがある人には知ることはできます
ものすごい感情的にキャーキャーと思う
もう迷ってる人にとっては何も知ることもできない
だから その 2つはいつでも総合的に成長するものなんです
で 次にポイントは書いてあるポイントで
この偏見と差別ということ
認識というものは差別
区別 判断なのです 目耳等で差を感じて
その差を認識するのです
これはちょっと専門的なお話になりますけど
仏教の中で心理学的に説明になりますが
説明いたします 私たちは何かを知るということはどういうことかというと
差を知るんですよ 差ということ
例えば空気に見えますか？あるのに空気は見えません
なぜならば何の差もないんですね
これでこういう建物やら
こういう黒板やら そういうものは見えます
全く同色になっちゃう
例えば あの 全くこの背景いろいろ入ってますけど
背景真っ白くして文字も真っ白くしちゃうと見えますかね
コントラストがないと
まあ試しにスライド 1 つ作って見せますけども
わからないんだったら全く真っ白いスライドで文字も真っ白くする
まるっきり見えないんですよ
だから見えるために 差が必要なんです
例えば 私の声が耳に入るでしょうに
それ違うんだから 瞬間瞬間耳に入るんですよ
だから全く同じだったら
もう認識できなくなっちゃうんです
例えば ある一定の音がずーっとあると聞こえなくなります
これがよく匂いという場合はあるんですよ
匂いっていうのは 同じ匂いがもう 2
3回  10回  20回嗅ぐと
もう全くわからなくなるんです
それから だから自分がどんな匂いかとわからないでしょ
本当は結構匂い持ってますよ
自分の匂いはわからない
それで面白いことに まあお年召していくと
もう鼻の感覚がね あの
ちょっと弱くなってくるし
特に女性の方なんか香水なんかもうとことんかけちゃう
で 本人でいい香りでいたいかもしれませんだけど
自分で感じるところまでかけますから
周りにとってはかなりあの距離を置いておかないと
ということになっちゃうんですね
だから鼻でよくわかることで
同じ匂いがほんのちょっとの時間続けてくると
もうオフになっちゃうんですね
舌もそうなんですよ 全く同じ味をずっと入れちゃうとわからなくなっちゃうんです
認識はしなくなるということは
私たちの頭がいいんだ
よくいろんなことを勉強しているんだとかね
というと この差をキャッチするんですよ
だから 頭が悪い人にとっては差をキャッチできる能力がない
これとこれと違いますよと
これ 人の頭がいいか悪いかを決めるのは
勉強できるかできないかって
そういう時点で決めるんですよ
だから子供たちは小さい時からもこの差を教えていけてるんですよ
例えば 1歳  2歳の子供たちにも
まあ最初の教育ということで
もう三角のものやら丸いものやらね
あげてこの穴に入れることやらね
で それで子供はもう全然自由でない
もう動かない手で もう何か三角を持っていろんな穴に入れてみようかなとか見て
もうなんとか三角 この形だから
やっぱり穴はこの形の穴でいいんじゃないかなとかね
その差を勉強する だから子供たちに
ちっちゃな子供たちには形と色で
色で差を教えてあげる
だから 子供にはものすごく頭が鋭くなってほしいであれば
とことんいろんな差を教えることですよ
もうちょっと上になってくると
微妙な差を発見しなさいと
それでIQテストあるでしょ
日本語でもIQというんですね
あれはね 知能指数を測る IQ
テストの場合は 全部質問が差を発見する質問ですよ
出てくるのは 何のこともない
どちらが違うかと 選択は 5つぐらいあって
一遍見れば全部同じみたいに見えますけどね
だから差をさっとすぐ察知できる人だったら IQ IQ
の指数が高いんです そこでIQはたくさん点数取ったんだからって
よく勉強できる人って
それはまた別で勉強するかしら
人のやり方次第ですけど
そこらで何をチェックするかというと
基本的な能力 基本的な能力
だからサチにもゾウにもチンパンジーにもIQがあるんですよ
ですから この知る認識っていうのは知る世界だから
知るということは差を知ってること
差別ですよ だからこの差別っていうのは
別にもう悪い言葉じゃないんですよ
これが命なんですよ 知恵の
差別できないともうどうにもならん
もう生きていられない
差をわからないと 例えば
これは眼鏡です これはお箸ですとわかるのは差別ですよ
差別認識 だからそれはとても大事なことなんです
それを理解してください
次に書いているのは もうその差別
これ 英語で言えばディファレンス
認識に好き嫌いなどの感情が伴うと一般的に言う差別感
この感 正しいかないかちょっとわからないんですね
差別か  感情の感  でしょうかね
まあコンピューターは感情の感は出しちゃいますけどね
一応使いますけど 多分差別
差別 感も感情の感の方が使われてる
そういうことだそうです
この差別勘の勘は感情の勘
ちょっとまあ一応なんですけど
で あの この区別する仕事を感情が入り込み
入り込むと割り込むと差別感が生まれてくる
ディスクリミネーションというものが生まれてくる
これがみんな嫌がるものなんですよ
人を馬鹿にすることですからね
人を他を軽視することだから
貶すことだから だから差別感が悪いんだからといって差別が悪いわけじゃないんです
それで分かりますかね
我々はすごい差別が 差別能力あるならば
ものすごく頭がいいというか
頭がすごく良くなる能力を持っている
差別能力があれば それに感情入っちゃうと世界最低の人間になる
だから感情を抜きにして
差別能力だけあれば 世界一流の天才みたいな知識人になる
この天才みたいな知識人になれる人に感情を入れてあげると最悪の人間になるんです
世の中調べて人間の調べてみてください
そういうことなんです
はい あの 私だけの感覚なのかもしれないですけど
差別って言ったらもう差別感と一緒で
普通区別だと あの  それは日本語の問題で
仏教用語では差別っていうのは普通に使うんです
これも私によって関係ない話で
この漢文日本語ではこのもう差別も区別も使っていて
またどちらも貶す場合もあります
例えば苦悩分別というんですよ
唯識理論では だから分別すること自体とんでもないことやと
区別すること自体とんでもないよと言いながら
差別区別という言葉を使っているんです
だから私はこの場合はあえて差別という言葉を使っているんです
区別という言葉は上書いたんですけど
区別判断というのは書いたんだけど
説明するときはもうあえて差別という言葉を使う
なぜかというと その差を知ってほしいんですよ
差別が良くて差別感が悪いんだと
それ知ってほしいんです
で 差別があるとすごい頭が良くなる
差別感が入っちゃうと最悪の人間になる
で 差別感っていうのは自分の感情が入る子も
どうか説明が例えばないんですかね
はい まあ例えばもう 元々また元に戻ってください
で 説明がね まあ一応ここは説明して終わって
もしなかったらまた元に戻して説明いたします
それで 知識智慧の元になるはずの差別が
結局差別感になると 感情が入っちゃうと仇になって返ってくるということ
これはバラの花ですと我々は差別する
でも同時に私は大嫌いですと
バラの花はとかね その気持ちが入り込んじゃうんです
嫌いな人だ 嫌いな人だったら
好きな人だったら ああ
これはバラの花ですねと
それで認識する だからそこが良くないということ
バラの花です あ これは人間ですと
アフリカ人ですと 黒人ですと
そうやってはっきりと差別して区別して知ってほしいんですよ
黒人なのにああ 日本人ですと勘違いしちゃうと困るでしょうに
うちの旦那と勘違いしちゃうと困るでしょうね
だから区別がないと差別がない
生きていられません だから子供の中で自分の子供は誰ですかと
何のことなくわかるでしょうに
泣き声でもわかるでしょうに
あのペンギンたちがね
ペンギンの子供とみんな同じで
大勢いっぺんに雪の上で育ててるでしょうに
でもきちんと自分の子供を知ってますよ
それと差別感 差別がないと
もう世の中成り立たないんです
しかし 黒人ですと言った途端に感情が入っちゃうと
その人も差別してるんです
微妙なんですよ 感情さえ入らなきゃね
何のこともない でも我々は生まれつきこの冷静沈着な能力ないんだから
もう感情入ってますよ
あの人黒人ですと言った途端
もうざーっとオブスみたいな感じで
すべての感情が入ってイメージが作り作って
そのイメージで見てしまう
そこでもう激しく激しくしますよ
関係はそこら辺はすごく
そうすると感情が入っちゃうと
我々の認識は全部仇になってくるんです
例えば科学の研究できる能力っていうのはありがたいことで
それに差別をごちゃまぜにしちゃうと
もう今の世の中なんです
危なくて生きていられない
世界であってはならないとならないことになってしまうんです
研究しては人を貶すために
人を殺すために 人を搾取するためにだけ
もう科学研究を発展してどんどん持っていく
それで研究者の間で互いにこのある憎しみやら
もうもうもう汚いというと
もうあんまりですよ それをもう科学世界でいる人々は
我々 私は関係ないんですからね
まあものすごく味わっているものだと思いますよ
知識人の研究者の仲間だから仲良くいればいいのに
全然ないんですよ ものすごい恐ろしい
知識人だから殺しはしませんだけど
それよりは知識的にはもっとひどいことをする
人の研究データを盗んだりとか
いろんなことをする あるいは一緒に研究して
もうなんとかごまかしつつ
自分が先に発表する それであの次の人にはどうすることもできなくなっちゃう
だからすごい怖い世界なんです
なぜかというと この知識人でしょう
知識人だから 明らかに私たち一般人よりは差別能力は優れているんですよ
これに入っちゃうんですね
感情が 自分が有名にならなくちゃとかね
自分がこれでもう特許を取って金もうけもうけしなくちゃとかね
それすごく仇になってくるんですよ
で 感情が割り込んだ差別
区別 認識が人を具体的な事実から主観的な妄想へ導くのです
この最後に書いてるポイント
難しいかどうかわからないんですけど
まあこう  1 行で言いたいことは全部言ってはいますけどね
例えばこういう例で見ます
バラの花ですと感情ない
ただ差別で見える差別を見ると何色ですか？とか
どれぐらいこれ大きくなってるんですか？とか
まあ切ってから何日経ってるかとかね
何から何までわかるんですよ
花びらのもうどうやって花一本一本違うんだからね
花びらのあり方やらね
バラの真ん中にあるあれやのおしべ
めしべありますね そこら辺の色々差があったりとかね
香りはどういう香りですかとかね
色の付き具合はどういうものですかとかね
いろんな智慧が現れてくるはずなんですよ
そうすると結構面白いんですよ
差別だけやれば しかし
感情を割り込んじゃうんだと
それで智慧がストップ
終わり 目にバラの花をきれいな花です
私は好きですよと そうすると自分の世界の中でぐるぐる回るんですよ
自分がなんでバラの花好きでしたか？とかね
いろいろもう妄想の世界に行くんです
この目の前にある花が見えなくなるんです
やっぱり私は育ったところで
田舎でもいっぱいバラの花畑ありましたとかね
あるいは自分にはもう最初に恋した人から
そのバラの花一本もらったとかね
学校でとか まあそれからその花を見ると
あの感情が思い出したりとかね
これでバラの花を見ていますかね
その人は その人は残念なことに智慧がストップしちゃったんです
だから差別感がそれから差別は差別能力がそれからは成長しない
感情入っちゃう そういうことで
感情が入ると 我々のせっかく智慧の道が妄想の世界になってしまいます
はい それで差別偏見差別の ２番目 ２
番目だよ 続き 自分だけの主観の世界を作ると
真理 事実から遠ざかるのです
妄想の世界に囚われて無知の闇に落ちるのです
人間みんなそういう派になっているんです
真理 事実はわからない
ただ 自分の主観の世界で生きている
なかなかこの妄想を破ることもできない
なぜでしょうかね もう差別能力に感情が入っちゃったんです
好き嫌いやらいろいろ感情が入っちゃったんです
それですごい恐ろしい結果になっていて
みんな昨日テレビで多事争論とかなんとか言ってる人がいますね
誰ですか？名前は えっ
筑紫哲也さん  そう 哲也さん
その人のニュース番組で３人のインテリの人々が来て
この戦争に対して一言葉で言うならば何なのかと
もう彼がものすごい立派な人で
言うことっていうのは
大体聞いて役に立つような言葉ばっかり喋る人でね
で まあ２人しかないんですよ
もう日本のマスコミでね
まあものすごい一般的で喋る
あのニュースステーションの人と
もうちょっとインテリ的なで
ちょっとクールで喋る
今 哲也さんという人ですけどね
そこで一人の人が これは妄想の戦争ですと
今の戦争に名前を付けちゃって妄想
妄想の戦争 私はよく言う
よく言ってるなと思ったんですよ
だからそれいろいろ説明して
まあまあ こういうこういうことを妄想して
妄想して妄想して それで妄想の結果として戦争をやっているんだと
すごいんですよ その観察の行くはね
そういうことですから
この妄想というのはひどいもんですよ
客観的には見ない ただ
自分の主観であいつは悪人だと思ったら
もう何だかんだ悪人ということになってしまっちゃう
それで私たちは大変なことになってます
このバラの花ですと見ないで
自分の自分が好きか 自分が嫌いか
どちらがなんとか個人的なこと入っちゃうと
もうそれから見えなくなって
自分の世界に入り込んじゃって
妄想ばっかり回転して
それで知恵がなくなる
ストップする だから人が何喋っても
何を見ても 人の話をいくら聞いても
何一つも世の中で役に立たない
仏教から見れば 人間いうことは一つも当てにならない
で それでもお釈迦様はいくらか道徳的な考え方はあまり批判しないで置いておいたんですけど
それを私はもう一歩進んで
人間いう道徳も当てにならないんだと
くだらないんだと 成り立たないんだと
ところまで私はちょっとまあ先に狂暴的に言いますよ
そういうことで 次に帰っていったのですから
区別 差別 判断なしに認識は成り立たない
認識なしに知ることは成り立たない
知ることはなしに智慧は成り立たない
智慧がないと無執着もない
無執着はないと自由も解脱も平安もありません
すっごくつなげているんですよ
だから区別判断は必要です
しかし 区別感 差別感はとんでもないことです
区別判断すると認識がどんどん増えていく
認識が増えていくともう知ることでしょう
いろんなことを知ることができますよ
知れば知るほど知恵が発展する
開発する だから知れば知るほど執着が消えちゃう
執着が消えてしまうと自由になって
心がね 大変平安 喜び 安らぎを感じることができます
だから この 書いてますね
しかし これは花だと認識した瞬間に好きだ
嫌いだ 面白くないのだという大体 3つの感情
貪瞋痴ですからね 入りますけどね
などの感情が入ると差別感が現れ
また間違ってる勘が入ってます
差別感が現れ 客観的な見方から主観へ逆戻りしているのです
これが無知の始まりです
平安ではなく 苦しみに進むのです
だから世の中はいくら経っても苦しみから苦しみへ生きているんですよ
今苦しいと頑張って苦しみへいくんです
みんな頑張ってます 頑張っても頑張っても結果は苦しみなんです
その悪循環がそういう理由で出てきているんですね
そこら辺は一応ものすごくポイントは難しいんですけど
でも自分に当てはめて考えると
そんなに難しいってことでもない
差別と差別感 微妙で差別は良くて
感情が入るともう終わりと地獄だと
差別だけ差別だけだったら天国だと
それぐらいで覚えておけば
差別能力だけだったら
もう天国行き幸福行きで
差別感だったらもう地獄行きだと
それで勘が入っていると智慧がない
無知になる 妄想になる
差別能力だけだったら
いくらでも智慧が開発していく
はい で まあそういうところで
この難しいところは終わりました
それからこの次のポイント
まあこの冷静なウペッカーがあるとトラブルがない
トラブルにならない ウペッカーは感情に左右されない客観的な見方です
当たり前のことですからね
ウペッカーっていうのは
感情に汚染された見方では
ありのままの事実を見えません
判断は偏見 独断になります
当然反対の意見の人もいます
自分の判断以外の判断もあり得ることも理解できない
それが他とぶつかることになり
戦うことになるのです
わかりやすい 私にはわかりやすいんですけど
説明する必要ないなと
で 今まで言ったような感じで
この感情に この我々の差別能力が汚染されちゃうと
これがもう偏見になって
ありのままの事実は見えなくなる
自分に見える世界になるんですね
そこで自分に見える世界で自分が判断するものはすべて独断偏見なんです
これ どうにもならないんですよ
そこでどうなるかというと
私がバラの花はもう綺麗ですと好きですと決めておく
他の人はもういや こんなの大したことない
面白くないと言うでしょうに
違う意見も出てくるんですよ
それで私は あれ この人変だと
バラの花が嫌いと言うんだから
綺麗じゃないと言うんだよ
こんな綺麗なのにと 相手のことを変やと思っちゃう
理解もできない だから自分だけの意見で生きてる
まあ政治家と同じと 相手が言うことは理解もできない
で  で 理解できないんだからぶつかるんですよ
自分言ってることが正しいんだぞと言って
相手と喧嘩するは ぶつかるはもう別れるは
戦争までするわ 戦争して人殺しもなんだかんだもしてしまいます
ということで このトラブルでは
この感情をカットして
好きでもない 嫌いでもない目ですごい沈着冷静な目で見たり
聞いたり 考えたりすると
そのトラブルは 1つも起きません
全くぶつかることは起きません
誰も不幸になることはないんですよ
まあ一応そういうことでわかりやすいですね
次に それであの次のポイント
問題を全体的に見える
全体的に言うと この感情で主観で見る場合は 1側面しか見えない
人の意見にも耳を傾けようとしてもうまくいかないし
難しい 努力してもやがてストレスが溜まって疲れる
これで感情で物事を見る場合はね
まあ当たり前である側面しか見えません
例えば日本人がご飯を見る
アメリカ人がご飯を見ると同じく見えません
自分たちに見える側面があるんです
椅子でそこまでわかるでしょ
例えば着物を着ている人を日本人が見る
アメリカ人が見る 口であ
綺麗やと言ったっても同じじゃないんですよ
全くも違う見方は 全くも違う
で 自分に何か見えたり感じたりすると
我々はすぐ頑固になって人の話を聞かないことにする
いつでも日常生活であること
なぜ人の話を聞かないかというと
自分の意見に意見にしがみすぎてわからないんです
親言うことは子供は全然わからない
頑固になって 子供が言うことは親にわからない
親も頑固で 互いに理解できなくなっちゃうんです
子供に至っても これが好きやと欲しいと思っちゃうと
全部見えなくなっちゃうんです
とにかく買ってくれと
でもう責めるだけです
で これがわかっている我々がもうちょっとインテリぶろうとするんですよ
人の意見も聞いてみようではないかと
これについて一応ちょっとディスカッションしてみようと
あれは所詮無理ですよ
能力持つことないんだから
自分に意見があって まあ一応インテリ的で
まあ知識的にはやっぱり人のみんなの意見を聞いてみようとか言って聞くんだけど
ものすごく疲れる 意見聞いても
あれ これ何という意味でしょうかと
わからないんだからね
なんでその人こういうことを言うんでしょうかと
では 次の人の意見はどうでしょうかと
それまた同じことで でもわからなくなりますね
では どんな判決しますかというと
もうできなくなるんですね
この独裁者が現れるのはそういうわけなんですよ
しちめんどくさいと 人の意見を聞くのは
私が思っている通りにやるぞと
世の中に独裁者が現れる原因は
まあこれ あまりこのややこしい難しいことをやりたくないと
人の意見を聞くと全く正反対のことを言ったりするし
もうやりきれないなと言って独裁的になると
だから独裁者になる あの恐れっていうのは
どんな人間にも大体 70%ぐらいあります
これ  75 6になると 本当に独裁者になっちゃうんですよ
日本でもいろんな会社経営などでね
まあワンマンでやって
どれほど他人に迷惑 苦労をかけて
もう社員たちもみんなクビになったりとかね
何回も起きおりましたから
あの 一番大きい総合とかね
そういう場合でも 全部ワンマン経営で
ものすごい大きいでしょうも挟んで
なんでそうなるかというと
めんどくさいと思うでしょ
もう会議やってもやっても何言うかさっぱりわからないというかね
自分の意見とは違うわ
どうしようもない 自分でやるぞと
で やったところでまた倒産と
みんなの意見聞いたっても倒産する
そうやって一人だけワンマンショーでやったっても
まあ倒産してしまうということはよくあるんですよ
そういうことで疲れますよ
それを認めてもらわないとね
ただ 我々はちょっと知識的で
まあ私はあえて知識ぶっちゃうということを使いますけど
本来知識じゃないんですよ
知識人じゃないんです
まあ感情があるんだから
静寂 冷静な見方を持ってないんだから
ウペッカー持ってないんだから
しかし 話を聞いたことがあるんだから
人の意見も聞かないとうまくいかないんだぞというところで
ただ頑張ってるだけ 人の意見を聞こうと頑張ってるんだけど
疲れますよ 本当にもう
もう嫌になってきますよ
ストレス溜まって溜まって
ということで ただみんなの意見を聞いただけで正しいわけでもないんです
よく覚えておいてください
また 多層の見方が現れて
どちらが良いのかわからなくなる
人の意見を聞くとそれになるんですよ
意見が多数になるでしょうに
ではどちらが正しいですか？わからなくなるんですね
一つのものについて無限に意見
見解が成り立つ それ知ってますか？何かについてあなたの人の意見を聞くと
無限に意見成り立つんですよ
では 結論は出せますかね
しかし 本当のことはいまだ知らずです
これ全部意見であって
事実真理じゃないんだから
あんたどう思いますか？あんたどう思いますか？あんたどう思いますか？でしょ
日本 みんな私はこう思います
私はこう思いますと 一人の人にも思うことはいくらでも作られますからね
では正しい答えは何なのかと
まだないんですね それで例を出してますよ
例 アメリカとイラクの戦争についても考えてください
それで アメリカ人の見方
イギリス人の見方同じですか？と
今 アメリカとイギリスは一緒に戦争しているでしょ
だから あの国２つが同じ考え方と思いますかね
全く違うんですよ 自分たちの考え方は
アメリカ人が人殺しに行っているのは別なわけがあって
イギリス人がそれに飛んで参加するのはまた別なわけがあって
オーストラリア人が行ってやっているのはまた別なわけなんですよ
だから意見ものすごい違うんですよ
だからどちらの意見正しい？イギリスのなんとか人の意見正しいんですかね？ブッシュさんの意見正しいんですかね
？オーストラリアの総理大臣の意見正しいんですかね
まあオーストラリアは恐らく白人至上主義でやっていると思いますけどね
イギリス人はまた違うんです
で アメリカはまた別 あれは個人的な感情で
で これこれ違うでしょうし
それで日本人も まあ日本人というか
日本もまあ戦争は支持するとか言っても
ではアメリカ人と同じ考え方で支持していますかね
それでブッシュさんが私と同じ考え方
日本人の政府 日本の政府もありますよと言ったっても
まるっきり違うでしょ
日本の総理の発表によると
また見方が別なんですね
ただ アメリカが偉いんだから支持するだけの話なんです
よくよく見ると 他は全然考えてない
すごい単純で アメリカが偉い
断れない まあ断ることできない
同盟なんとかなんとかあるんだからと
で 同盟うんぬんというのは
別に他の国々も同盟的な国ありますよ
でも断りますけどね 断る時は
やっぱりこちらではまあ一応断らないという
まあ偉いということでね
まあ一応支持すると しかし
誰かが国際法律をちょっとでも破っちゃうと
あの声のでっかさ でも明らかに国際法律破ってますよ
アメリカは でもだからそういうふうにいろいろ意見違うんですよ
私が言いたいのはそれだけ
自分に見える世界 よくわかるでしょう
結局は日本の政府の見方も
そんな正しいとは言え
ないし だからといってどうすることもできないし
もうアメリカの意見も決して正しいわけじゃないし
だからといってどうすることもできんしね
それでイラク人の見方はどうですかね
この戦争について信じられないほど違うでしょ
アッシェ人がその戦争についてどんな意見を持ってるかと
そういう風にイラクの今
爆撃 攻撃 攻撃されている
それについて正しいことって何なのかと聞いてわかりますかね
無限に無数に意見が出てきます
では 例えば一人の人が調べたっても
すべての地球の人間に聞かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですよ
みんな自分の別な意見を持ってるんだから
それから僕みたいな人間に聞いちゃうと
もう 40種類ぐらい意見言うんですよ
1本じゃなくて そうするともっと困っちゃうんです
それは一番困るんですよ
同じ人が意見 2つ言うことは
聞く人はすごく困るんです
ですから このしかし それほど 4億円
10億円  100億円 意見を調べても答え出ます
これがこの主観の見方の恐ろしさなんですよ
いくら研究しても答えが出てこない
なぜかというと みんなある側面でしか見ない
自分の感情でしか見ない
だから 沈着冷静な心で見ましょうと
感情は捨てましょうと
これがとんでもない危険なものよ
というのは 仏教の立場から感情を捨てて見ると
全体的に見える 例えばイラクの問題にとっても全体的に見えてしまうんです
だからその場合は全体的に見える人にとっては
じゃあ答えを言ってくださいって言われても
それはすごい もう普通の人間の知恵が飛んでいるものだから
まあそれは言いにくいものですけど
だから私はちょっと試してみたんです
例として出そうと思って
例えばイラクについて答えは何なのかと
で そう 全体的に見ると
そう簡単じゃないんですね
そうするとまた分析しなくちゃいけない
まあ私は戦争反対だ 人を殺すことを仏教は全く明らかにもう断固として反対だから
で 私は仏教の目で見る
殺さずに済むためにはどうすればいいかと
で どこで間違っているか
それで例えば一人に絞ってみる
フセインという人に フセインという人に絞ってみると
その人が自分のわがままね
この権力欲っていうのはね
最初からもう抑えておけばよかったんじゃないんでしょうかね
自分もいろんな苦労して
苦労して 貧しい家庭で生まれて
一生懸命頑張ったんで頑張ったんだから
その自分のいいところだけで生きていればよかったんじゃないんですか
それで出す戦争 いい人ですよ
よく頑張ったんだから
ですから 自分のいいところを見て
まあこれからもうクーデターやって大統領になったっても
やっぱりこれから同じ国民のために
自分みたいな苦しんでる人たちっていっぱいいるんじゃないですかと
だからもうことごとく国を発展させて
平和な国を作るぞとと思っちゃえば
別に問題はありませんでしょうし
でも自分の権力を握るということで
そこで判断ミスを犯す
自分主観に見るんだからね
そこでクルディシュ人やらいろいろ同じイスラム教の宗派があるんだから
そちらの問題が起きたりすると
それまた自分の民族と自分の宗派を守ろうとするという
そちらが正しい そこで内戦
いろんな問題が出てくる
そこら辺で民主主義にした方がよかったのに
でも自分の主観を捨てられる捨てることはできない
そこでまた判断ミスでしょうし
過去のことだから 今はどうったことないんですけどね
次にその人がもうもうもう特権も傲慢
わがまま 権力はもう膨張する
膨張したところでイランの問題が出てきて
イランの宗派がすごく違う
同じイスラム教の だからやつけなくちゃいけないと
隣の国を侵略する そこで悪魔と手を組む
イスラム教ではアメリカって悪魔なんです
悪魔と手を組む イランを攻撃するために
それで全部技術をいただく
破壊兵器作る生物兵器の作り方とか
全部技術をどんどん来る
それをもってイラン攻撃して
まあ別なところに行って
アメリカからよしよしやれやれという感じで
で それが終わったところで
物はまだ持っている そこでクウェートをやっちゃったんですね
武器があるとなんかやらないとね
そちらでも判断ミス この仲間というか
アメリカの仲間でしょ
それやっちゃうと アメリカの武器でね
アメリカはそれを認めないしね
そういうことでどんどんどんどんエスカレートしていっちゃうんですね
だから どこかで彼がストップした方がね
主観を捨てた方が それで問題解決するはずでしたしね
そこで戦争が終わった時でも
私が言うのは 彼経済制裁前にこの査察ってものが入ったでしょうに
この査察が入った時点で
彼がいろんな国から査察団来るんじゃなくて
アメリカから来て査察しなさいと言ったならば
その問題は 1週間で解決する
査察団はアメリカ人でなければいけません
と ちょっと意見出しちゃえばね
通りますよ 国連で意見
あの提案出すのはアメリカだから
だからそういう鋭さもない
通ったところで まあ私は知ってます
アメリカはどういう風に査察するかっていうことは
もうイラクはアメリカを敵で見てないんだからね
もう仲間だからね よしよしよしと背中を叩いて １週間で帰るんです
もう大丈夫 もうもうその国はもう戦争しないと
そこで経済制裁も解除になっちゃうし
まあそれでまあ万々歳になるはずでしたしね
これでもうアメリカ人はスパイするんだと
まあ確かにスパイに来たんですけど
させればよかったのに
初めから で そういう知識がなかった
それであの今の苦しい状況を回避できたんですけど
できなかった 次にこの人は殺しに来たでしょうし
まあそれでまあ 彼がもう長い間やったことだから
もういいでしょうに 別に
死ぬまでやらなくても
ずっと怯えて 自分の親戚にまで怯えて生活するよりはね
それでまあ 私がいる場合は
もうイラク国民にとってはなかなか大変だと
私は何よりも自分の命より国民のことを大事にするんだよと
ですから 私は辞任しますと
国のためにと言ったら
名誉あって辞任して ものすごく万々歳でいられたはずなんです
そういう やっぱりこの主観で生きてるんだから
そういうの浮かぶことさえないんですね
だから今殺されるまで待つしかないんですね
殺されたっても ものすごい惨めな犬猫みたいな死に方でしょ
だから この偏見で主観で生きていると
そういう風などんどん感情が出てきて
かわいそうな運命になるの
たとえイラクを攻撃するのは悪いとかなんとか言っても
結局個人個人が自分にやっている行いのような
得るべき結果得てしまうだけなんですよ
結局は だから仏教はあの人が悪い
この人が悪いじゃなくて
そうやって客観的に見ようとする
それで今私は解決方法をいくらか過去形で言ったんです
まあ現在形でも将来形でも言えますけど
言っても理解できないんだからね
これをもう沈着冷静な目で見る人
見る人にしか出てこないんですからね
そういうのをいつでも何かニュース見たって
普通にポツンポツン この場合はこうした方が何でやれてやらなかったと
ってよく見えますよ そういうふうなことで
この問題っていうのは
例えば全体的に見える
全体的に見えて答えを出すっていうのは
すごくかなり智慧が開発していないとできないってことになります
はい 次に行きます えーと
自分の好き嫌いを外して
事実だけを観察する この全体的な見方
データだけを見る 因果関係を見る
長所 短所を見る 人の感情的な偏見に対しては無関心になる
しかし その人にも見えた事実があれば
それを取る 実はそれはほとんどいらないんです
客観的にこの沈着冷静に見ると
人の意見は意見を聞く必要ないんです
楽ですよ 見えてるんだから
だから世の中でみんなの意見を聞きましょうっていうのは本当に成り立たないんです
仏教では なんで人の意見を聞くんだい
自分で見ればいいでしょ
たまにありますから 例えばもうもう
アメリカ人が悪人だ 悪魔だというイスラム人の人々はおかしいではなくて
その人々はなんでそんなことを言うんでしょうかというと
その原因見つかるんですよ
もう考えたこともないでしょ
イスラム教から見れば
もう悪魔はもうアメリカなんです
サタンは だからテロなんか別にそんなに気にしない
人が死んだっても それでイスラム人がもう全く頭がおかしいということでもないんですよ
その人々によく話を聞くと
そちらにもいろいろ原因になるものは見えてくるんですよ
ですから 人の意見を聞いて
聞いて そのデータだけを取る
あ なるほど あなたはこういう風にやられたんですかと
あ なるほど あなたの見方だったら
こういう見方でしょう
そのデータだけを取る
別に意見に乗ること 乗ってしまうことじゃないんです
実は自分で見ると まああんまり人の意見を聞く必要はなくなるんですよ
で 感情で見ると見方 見解は無限ですが
客観的に事実だけを見ると
見解というものは一つもありません
だからこのパロンは生まれません
悩む必要もない だから悩む必要もないんです
これについてどうしようか
あの人はこう言ってるわ
この人はこう言ってる
あの人はこのように言ってる
また別な人は別なこと言ってる
ああ 悩んだ 困った どうしようかとちゃんと見てみると
一つしかないんだから
意見は 客観的に事実だけを見ると一つしかないんです
それはウペッカーです
ウペッカーというものなんです
だからウペッカーで見ると
答えが一つで返ってくるんです
これしかないんだ だから
何千 何億も意見の中でも
どうにもならない状態にある人がウペッカーで見ると
答えこれっていう はっきりくるんですよ
それから次のポイントも解決方法を見つかる
問題を全体的に見てない人の解決方法は皆納得するものではありません
だから世の中でみんなね
解決するでしょ いたく納得いかないでしょ
今までの歴史的な事実を見ると
自分の家族のことを見ると
自分の家族でもいろんな解決方法
解決方法 解決法 日々あるでしょうに
でも一つも納得いかない
うまくいかない だからやってみなきゃわからないという日本の有名なことわざですけど
で という立場で決断するのです
これは無知な人のやり方なんです
はっきりわかってない
沈着冷静に物事を見ない
主観で見て とんでもない無知になっている人が
やってみなきゃわからないやと平気で言う
そんなにも不満でやるんですかね
それで 決断するのです
えーと やってみたところで別な問題が起きたり
さらに問題は悪化したり
また何の解決にもならなかったりするのは保証済みです
あの それわからないんだったら
日本の経済状態をね なんとかするんだぞと
いろいろ解決策練ってるでしょ
何の解決にもなってないんです
悪いのはそのまんまなんです
だから このやってみなきゃわからないというやり方でやっているんだからなんですね
それで客観的に見て 問題を把握している知恵のある人に
解決方法も明確に見えてくるのです
それも一つの案ではなく
これしかないというと言える唯一な解決策なのです
だから ウペッカーで見るということはいかにありがたいかと
ウペッカーで見ると あ
こうしましょう これ私の案ですよという答えじゃないんですよ
案じゃないんです ウペッカーの人に出てくる
これしかない あるんだったら言ってみろという態度で答えが出てきます
えーと 誰の見方にも振り回されない
振り回されてないので
反論は成り立ちません
で ウペッカーで見る人の行動には誰も反論しません
この例で言えば お釈迦様には誰にも反論できなかったんです
お釈迦様は堂々と人のことを批判したりもしましたし
誰も殺そうとしなかったし
反論できん もう堂々と反論しようとした人も
もう間違えましたと お釈迦様を攻撃しようとした私はなんとバカですかということに
一瞬でそうなるんです
それはもうウペッカーで物事を見ていたんだからなんです
無知な人は驚くばかりの正しい解決なのです
だからウペッカーから解決方法を見せると
みんな驚くんですよ 口が開けるだけで
私は反対だよと言えません
それでまあ一応まとめていったのは
この下 心理の世界では
問題に答えは一つだけです
二つはないです はい 後を引きずらないということ
それは読んでみればわかるでます
ちょっと喧嘩をしても
自分の意見を却下されても
ほとんどの場合はね それを忘れられなくなって悩むことになるんですね
それで悩み 恨みやら憎しみやら落ち込みやら
いろんなものを苦しみが出てきます
たとえ我々は色々出っ歯で喧嘩でもするでしょ
する ちょっと喧嘩 でも後でもう悩んじゃうんですね
勝っても負けてもなんかどうかで納得いかない
例えば自分が意見を言ったところで
何言うんですかと 黙っていなさいと言われちゃうとえらくショック受けちゃうんですよ
それで後引きするんですよ
で あの ということで 過去を引きずる
は人間にとっては苦であり
不幸なのです 仏教の教えは全部一行ぎゅぎゅっとまとめてぎゅぎゅっと入れちゃったんです
人間にとって苦は何なのかと
不幸って何なのか それを一行で言ってるんです
過去を引きすることです
では 私たちはいろいろ苦しみあるでしょ？悩みもあるでしょ
考えてみてください 何やったらいいか
あれはもう主観で物を見て
あの感情でずっと引きするだけなんです
だから主観っていうのはもうあまりにも危険な苦しみを作るもので
客観的に見るんだったら後を引きずらないんですよ
例えば客観的なウペッカの人が意見を言う
誰も私が反対と言えませんだから
言ったっても もう論理で
もうどういうわけで反対でしょうかと聞く必要もないし
こっちは知ってるしね
でもあなたはこういうことで
こういうことを考えることはありますか？と言えば
それで終わるでしょうね
そうすると相手がやっぱり私が間違った
私は自分のことしか考えてないんだよということになるんです
だから問題になり立てないんですね
後を引きずることっていうのは
本当は自分の意見を却下されちゃって
ウペッカーの人はそれでも冷静にいるってわけじゃないんです
これは勘違いです バカにされて
侮辱されて それでも鈍感で冷静にいるっていうのはいくらでもいますからね
そういう意味じゃないんですよ
バカにされようとしてもされないんです
非難されようしようと
相手がしても こちらは非難されないだけ
ウペッカの人が だから別に後を引きずることはないんです
頑張って後を引きずらないようにする必要もないんです
頑張って忘れよう 忘れよう
忘れ そんなの要りません
みんなそういうことするでしょ？悪いことは忘れましょう
早いうちにとかね あれ無理ですよ
そんなことしたっても引きずってきますからね
やっぱりウペッカー育てないと
えーと なぜそのようになるのですか？自分が出した結論
意見 取った行動などに主観などなどは主観的でありのままの状況を見た結果ではないのです
ないからですね 事実見ちゃうんじゃないんですよ
ありのままに ただ バラの花はありのまま見たんじゃなくて
自分の気持ちで見ちゃったんですね
だからそんな問題になっちゃうんですよ
したがって 自分自身も納得していないのです
本当は本人も納得していない
これがすごい面白いんですよ
我々もガチャガチャガチャガチャ意見いろいろ言ったりするでしょうに
でも 言ってる人も納得いってないんです
完全に これしか答えがないぞと言う時でも
どこかで不安があるんですよ
もうちょっと調べていった方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
もしかすると違う意見もあるんではないかなとかね
こんな世界でよく生きてるんですよ
みんな まだ喧嘩をする
自分の意見を正しいと思って言ってる時でも納得して
例えば 仏さんが自分が言ってることに納得してないでしょうに
どれほど苦労するかと
顔でわかるでしょうに
皆様 英語で直接聞いてみると
この感情と発音と これでよくわかるんですよ
この言葉を選んで この英語ではこれアクセントを入れるということを言葉にしますから
このアクセントを入れると
やるやると 私はね もうえらい不安でいると
自分言ってることはもう嘘でしょとわかってるんですよ
で これがどうやって世界の人々があの乗ってくれるかというね
だから言ってる本人さえも納得してない世界で我々は生きているんですよ
これ 仏さんだから他人事にしてはいけません
我々もそんなもんなんです
私たち言うことには全然納得いってない
それで別な方法でもあったのではという悩みがあるでしょうに
という疑問残りますから
忘れたくても忘れられないのです
過去は 過去で何かやったことで
やっぱり別の方もあったんでしょうという気持ちがあるでしょ
だから過去を忘れられない
引きずっちゃうんです
必ずも引きずる だからウペッカーがないとものすごい危険
このように主観は不幸を生み出すのです
ウペッカーの人は納得する意見を持つので落ち着いているのです
もう引きずることはない
どうしますか？休憩しますか
続けますか？まあ  4時15分
えっ じゃあちょっと次の財布出してみて
はいはい えーっと じゃあこれでいくらかのポイントを通してまとめますから
これで休憩いたします
この次のポイントは 後悔も自慢もせず済む生き方なんです
失敗者は後悔する 当たり前のこと
のこのこと書くんだからね
で たまにうまくいったら自慢する
これは普通の生き方なのです
この世で成功はたまたま起こるものです
自慢せざるを得ないものですね
だから世の中誰もウペッカーないでしょうに
だから事実見てないでしょうに
それでいい加減でやってみなきゃわからないんだぞということで
いろんなことをやるでしょうに
やったところでたまたま成功すると
やっぱり自慢する気持ちになりますよ
自慢したんだからって
もうもう次にやってみて下さいとできないんです
次はできない 客観的な人に
ウペッカーがある人に
繰り返しますけど 自然に正しい道を見えるので
後悔はありえない 自然にはこれが正しい道と知ってるんだから
後悔することはもう全く成り立たない
当たり前の結果なので
自慢の種にもなりません
自分がやったことでいい結果になるのは当たり前だからね
全然自慢にもなりません
例えば 車の運転すごい上手な人は
どこかへ車を運転して無事に帰る
今日は事故を起こしませんでしたよ
自慢できんでしょ 自慢しません
自分がもう車を運転できて上手な運転手だからね
だからウペッカーの人はもう自慢はしない
なに そんなこと自慢するの
まあ当たり前でしょということになるんです
自慢して殺すぐらいの無駄な時間もありません
あの時間殺すということは日本語で言わないね
はい 日本語で何と言いますか？英語では殺すと言うんですけど
時間つぶす  つぶす じゃあ潰してみてください
今日は単位というのは英語なんですよ
だから自慢して潰すぐらいの無駄な時間もありません
忙しいんですよ このウペッカーの人は
常に客観的に物事を観察して生きているので
心が充実して忙しいのです
だから退屈にもなりませんし
まあ結構忙しいと言ったっても大変なことでもない
ただ観察して続けているだけのことで
一旦ここら辺で休憩 休憩いたします
じゃあ10分間休憩  では続けます
はい それで最後の項目
最後っていうのはすごく楽しい言葉です
ハハハハ あの執着しない生き方
心の自由っていうのは
ウペッカーから生まれてくるんです
沈着冷静で見ないと 見られたものにとらわれます
感情が入ることで見方が瞬時に主観が変わります
自分だけの世界で見たものと一人相撲するのです
これはよく勉強してください
で 何か感情で見るということは
見る 聞く 考える なんでもいいんですけど
感情で考えた瞬間でもう自分の主観に妄想に入ってるんですよ
例えば黒人を見て 自分に感情がありますね
黒人はもう例えば嫌いだとかね
あるいは怖いだとかね
まあなんとか感情があります
まあ例えば怖いにしましょう
黒人が怖いという感情があって
黒人を見る 見たら あ 黒人だ
一緒に怖いっていう入るんですよ
入った瞬間で その人は何者かもうこれっきり見えないんですよ
それで心の中で怖いっていうことが回転して
で 一人相撲になるんですよ
これ妄想になるんですよ
一人相撲するたびに新しい感情が湧いてきて
さらに精神が混乱します
なので 黒人が怖いという感情が
もしかするとそこら辺に住んでる人かもしれません
そうするとそっちは会うかもしれません
ストーカーにされるかもしれませんとかね
いろいろ出てきますよ
感情が どうなるかわからない
この心の中で自己回転だから
それで精神的な異常で病気でしょうし
だからさらにさらに使ってはいけない
持ってはいけない感情が
この一人相撲でどんどんもうもう直せないほど強化するんですね
増えるんですよ もうどうにもならないことになる
本当はもともとも感情は育ってはいけないんですよ
毒なんですよ バカになる原因なんですけど
これが増えていく で さらに自分が客観的な
具体的な世界から離れて
妄想の暗闇に入り込むのです
で そんなことで どんどんどんどん妄想の世界に入り込んで
事実からもう遠ざかって遠ざかっていく
見たものの瞬間の一側面のみが脳裏にしがみついているだけであって
結局は見たのに見ていない
生きているのに生きていない状態になるのです
これ 私は文章で書いたんだから
意味は全部一言葉に入れようとするんです
お釈迦様の影響で で だからこの
よくよく地味にして読まないと
言ってることはわからなくなるかもしれません
で 見るものっていうのは瞬間変わるんですよ
瞬間瞬間 例えば黒人が笑っていても
自分が見た瞬間で笑っていた
だからといって その人は永久的に笑っているわけじゃないんですよ
例えば その人がもう機嫌が悪い瞬間があって
自分が見たらすごい黒人が機嫌が悪い顔を見た
どうせ体格の悪い黒人だから
機嫌が悪い顔でもかなり迫力があります
それで怖いと思ったところで
自分がそれ その顔しか知らないんですよ
でも人っていうのはすぐすぐ変わるでしょうに
だから その人に あの人に対して意見を聞いたっても役に立ちません
あの瞬間の一コマしか見てないんです
それから感情を入れちゃって
一人相撲をやってるんだから
一コマで 事実の これ みんないつでもよくやってることなんですよ
物事を瞬間 瞬間変わるのに
例えば人を殺した人がいたっても
秒単位で人を殺してるわけないでしょうに
人を殺したことがある人でも
ものすごく優しい時もあるし
ものすごく穏やかでニコニコと笑っている時もあるし
すごく怯えて落ち込んでいる時もあるし
凶暴な時もあるし いろいろですよ
それで私が見た瞬間に
そのコマだけ取って 感情でもう脳裏にしがみついてもらって
それだけで一人相撲するんですよ
だからそれはウペッカーでなくなってほしいんです
というわけで ウペッカーがない人は見ているのに
本当は見ていない まとめて言えば生きているのに生きてないんです
これでお釈迦様の言葉で言えば
いえ パマッタ ヤタアマッタ
パマッタっていうのは怠るという風に訳しますけど
それはもう主観で妄想で生きているっていうことなんです
その人々はヤタアマッタ
もう死んだも同然だよという
まあ一応お釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
また同じ文章を続きます
物事は常に変化しているのに
主観の人はそれを全くわからない
頭の中は一人住まいだから気づかない
思考は自我という軸をルーテンすることになるのです
だから この主観の人の思考っていうのは
自我中心にぐるぐる回っているだけ
妄想っていうのはそういうわけなんです
沈着冷静な人は客観的なデータのみを見るので
次から次へと起こる変化も知っています
判断しないんだからデータだけ取る
そうすると 例えばもう機嫌が悪い黒人の顔を見ると見る
次の瞬間も見る 次の瞬間にはその人は私の顔を見たんだから
あの 怖い顔が消えるでしょうに
ああ 怖い顔が変わった
それもわかるでしょうね
そして次に私を見たら
興味の顔が出てくるでしょ
で 興味の顔が出たりする
私たちはよく経験することで
この外人たちはいろいろ見るんだから
みんななんかもうもう関係ないような感じで
もうすごく寂しいし 日本にいるとかね
もうなかなか横の関係もないし
こうやってよく固まっているんですよ
でも 私たちなんか目に見に入った瞬間に
いきなりもう溶けてしまって
もうすごく笑顔が出てきて
知らない人なんですけど
挨拶する だからその変化っていうのは瞬時ですけど
面白く変化するんですよ
昨日の行くとこはなんかまあそれ
アジア系かか イスラム系の人やと思う
体格のいい人はなんかすごい硬くなって歩いていて
私は向こうからまず見たんです
見た瞬間全部溶けちゃって
それで挨拶して もうもうもうやってもう行ったんですけどね
瞬間なんで だからその瞬間でも
人の性格やら考え方やらものすごく変わるんですよ
だからこのデータだけ取っちゃうと結構面白くて変化見えるんですよ
智慧が次第に向上するのです
そうやって変化見えると
主観で判断しちゃうとダメなんです
だから何も判断しないでデータだけと
そうするとみるみるうちに智慧が向上していくんですよ
何かに囚われる暇はありません
仏教でよく言うでしょ？囚われてはいけないんだとか
そういうじゃなくて そんな暇がないんですよ
無常知っていると いつでもその瞬間の TPOに合っている見解を持っている
見解出したっても それも瞬間瞬間のことだから TP
に合っている見解だけなんで
次は別っていう いつでもインスピレーションに溢れている
だからいつでもインスピレーションになるんですよ
知っては捨て去る 遊業社なのです
知っては捨て去るという
悩みも煩悩もひとかたもありません
心が自由なのです このようなわけで
賢者は幸福であると言われるのです
...というか このようなことを賢者が幸福と定義するんですよ
この状態は まあ賢者幸福である
幸福っていうことは当たり前ですけど
賢者が幸福というのはこの状態なんです
ウペッカーの状態なんです
楽しいんですよ それ 知識的な楽しみなんですよ
だから自分が今思ったことをすぐに自分で変えるんだから
変えたっても 次また変えなくちゃいけないんでしょうし
それでインスピレーションやら新しいアイデアがいくらでももうあるんです
キリがなく まあそういうことで
じゃあまあ一応そこら辺で
まあ一応ポイントは全部終わりました
次のスライドはどうなってますかね
まあただ意見だけね もう最後の結論ですね
沈着 冷静 平等 客観 智慧
まあどちらでもいいんです
ウペッカーには は生まれつき相続するものではありません
わかっていることでしょうね
冷静な見解は育てるものです
人は主観から客観へと進歩するべきものです
だから今私たちはそうではありません
だからこれからあの素晴らしいウペッカーを育てなくちゃいけないんですね
これを英語で言えばマンイズノットボーンワイス
バットビカムワイス ワイスっていうのは智慧のことで
だから日本語難しいと思うんだったら
英語の文章で覚えておいてください
難しくてわからないと
だから最後に言いたいのはマンイズノットボーンワイス
バットビカムワイス 次のスライドありますかね
エンディングですね  まあエンディングになりますね
じゃあ一応この今ずっと言ったのは
ウペッカーはすごいそう
すごいそうという話なんですよ
で あのまあ一部欠けているんです
時間がなくて これどうやって育てればいいかというね
では 私はもうウペッカーはない
主観で妄想で生きているという私はどのようにあのウペッカーの人間になるかと
お釈迦様おっしゃっているヴィパッサナー実践方法っていうのは
ウペッカーを育てるためなんです
はっきりと だから見るものは見えたと
聞いたものは聞いたと
これは何だろうと考えないでください
感じたものは感じたと
例えば怒りが出てきたら
もうそれは失敗なんですけど
怒りが出たら怒りに過ぎて考えていけないんです
それは妄想です 怒ってる
怒りがある それでストップするんです
ストップできるんだったら
怒り 怒り 怒り 怒りともうずっと言い続くんです
できる人にとっては 瞬時にあっ
怒ったなと自分でわかるんですよ
あ 怒った 瞬時に変えるんです
それは変えられるんです
そう変えられない場合は
怒り 怒り 怒りと呼ぶんです
例えば 人 自分が人の部屋に入る
入った瞬間で本当に迷惑ですねとか
なんとか その人は何か独り言を大きい声で喋っていると
そこで入った人がびっくりしちゃって
なんだろうね 私のこと嫌がって嫌がってるんでしょうかねとかね
部屋に入ったことは もうそんなこと言われると困るんだとかな
もう妄想で全部 疑が生まれたらもうダメなんですね
ただ声 音を出す 困ってるんだと言ってる
日本語わかってるんだから
困ってるんだと もし興味あるんだったら聞けばいいでしょ
あんた何に困ってるんですかねとかね
それ聞かないで 我々は自分で推測する
それやめてください 特にテレビでやっていることは絶対にやらないでください
どう思いますか？と それはどう解釈すればいいかと
全部合ってないでしょうに
嘘ばっかしで 知らないでしょうに
どう何が起きてるかと
戦争のことは この評論家みたいにもう軍事評論家が出て
日本で平和な国にあること
いること いること 武器の専門家やらね
それはどこらのバカ者たちかと思いますけどね
そんなに知りたければ
アメリカの軍隊も退院している人でも呼んでね
通訳つけて聞けばいいんでしょうに
するわけでもないでしょうに
だからそういう余計なことで世界が狂っちゃうし
私たちも狂う 私たちもそれに乗せられますからね
本当に困るんですね だから
この これ育てる方法っていうのは
えーと その時その時のこと
見たものは見ただけでストップする
聞いたことは聞いただけでストップする
感じたことは感じるだけでストップする
妄想はしないことにする
引きずらないようにする
持ち運ばないことにする
それはそれ 次のことをね
覚えておかないんです
しかし 心配しないでください
この瞬間瞬間に見ていると
必要な時は見事にその出来事をそのまま出てくるんですよ
私もいつでも例を出すのはそういうわけなんです
いくらでも例あるんです
それは忘れるんだからあるんです
今日もいくつかデータ取ったんだけど
それは今日はあまり合わないんだから別の日で使うと
でも覚えてはおかない
その TPO になってくると
あっ ああいう出来事があったと
出てきますよ ですから
このそういうふうに育ててほしい
この客観性 受け入れということ
それから質問がありますね
この質問を見てみると
誰でもやってる問題 間違いなんですけど
この質問に出ているんです
落ち込んでいる人 苦しんでいる人を見ると
近くにいる自分の心にも波が立つように思います
その人の気持ちを理解して
慈悲の心を起こすのは悪くないでしょうが
感情的に同情してしまって一緒に落ち込んでしまってはあまり役に立てないようです
慰めにはなるという意見もあるでしょうが
適度な距離を置く おせっかいを焼きすぎない
相手のペースに引きずられる
乗せられないというのは結構難しく感じますと
それについて説明してほしいと
それがだいたい世間の勘違いなんです
この沈着冷静っていうことは
そういう話だと 人が落ち込んでいると
それを沈着冷静で対応すればいい
できるわけないでしょうに
自分にもないんだから
私はそれを気をいたかったんです
だから私たちやろうとする冷静っていうのはインチキですよ
人が悩んでいると こっちは冷静に
冷静に 冷静に まあまあいいでしょう
大丈夫でしょうとか なんとか
こちらの冷静じゃないんですよ
だったら冷静ぶるよりは一緒に同情した方がやりやすい
その方がカウンセラーの場合でもうまくいくんですよ
例えば 人が何かにあってすごく怒って
大体奥さん同士よく喋るでしょ
旦那に怒って また他の奥さんとも喋るんで
その時その奥さんもすごく怒るんですね
そうですね やっぱりこれはけしからんです
それで落ち着くんですよ
二人とも同情したんだから
同じ感情になったんだから
でもそんなことで生きても生きていられませんだからね
怒る人を見ると自分も怒るわ
泣いてる人を見たら自分も泣くわっていうのはね
これもやりやすいんだけど
あれ あんまりにも大変なやってはいけないことなんですね
それでみんな考えるんです
だから 人が泣くたびに私も泣くと
いつ泣き止めますかね
キリがないでしょう いつ見たって人が泣いてるんだから
人が悩むと 私もすごい菩薩の心を抱いて
もう悩んであげると それだったら永久的に悩みっぱなしの人生になるんですよ
そんなのはもうあまりにも間違ってるやり方で
で わかった人々は やっぱり人が悩んでも
こちらが冷静に落ち着いて対応するんだぞとは自分に言い返すんだけど
これもできないんですよ
今日私が言うのはそれなんです
私たちは俗世間で沈着冷静になろうとしても
無理だからやめなさいと
その代わりに 今日から
今から沈着冷静っていうものは全く違うことで
これ 知恵に関わることで
知識人の仕事で だから今から育ててみようと
いわゆるビカムワイズ
今から頭いい人間になろうではないかと
頭のいい人間になるためには
物事は観察することでいいストップです
だから このおせっかい焼きすぎにならないようにとね
で やり方っていうのはやっぱり沈着冷静な態度なんですけど
で その時観察するんですね
あなたはなんで悩んでるんですかと
どういうこと起きたんですかと
それはデータだけ取る
それであなたにはそのことについて
例えばあの旦那が2日間家に帰ってないんだと
で 奥さんが悩んでると
なんで悩んでるんでしょうか
旦那が 2 日間家に帰ってないと
なるほど で ではそれはなんで悩むんですかと
そのことについては いつでもその人はいろんなところに行って
もう 2 日間家にいないということは今まで全くもなかったんですかと
そういうふうにいろいろ調べればいいんです
調べて調べていく間で
相手方が正しく自分のデータを出してるんですよ
質問するとそれで治ってるんです
客観的な観察する こちらで何も言うことは要りません
だから乗せられるとか
そんな問題じゃないんです
だから客観的に見るならば悩まないはず
この人は悩んでるっていうことは客観的に見られていないんだから
それで客観的に見させる
見させても本人見なきゃあかんだから
こちらで質問だけしてみればいいんです
ずっと質問していくと
その環境がそのまんまで
その人の頭にもう一度リピートされて入るんですよ
そこで本人はやっぱりバカバカらしいと
最後に本人言うのは こんなことに悩んだってバカバカらしいやと
そういう風に持っていくんですよ
そこでまた世の中でよく言われることをね
そこで冷静クールということで頑張ると
知らないうちに冷たい
無視して見せてる 見捨ててる
見殺し 解き放し 関係ないやというやり過ぎになることがあります
そこら辺ではこういう中で説明ありましたとはあるとは思いますけどね
いわゆる冷静でクールでいると頑張るというところが問題なんですね
別に頑張る必要ないんです
楽ですよ 冷静に見るっていうことはね
これは知恵で考えてないんですね
冷静イコール知恵なんです
ウペッカーっていうのは知恵なんです
ですから あの この見殺しとかね
解き放すとか そういうふんなふうに言われないんですよ
だから 本当の冷静に見る人だったら
相手がそんな反応しないんです
あ この人は全部知ってるんだぞとわかってるんです
この人 私より私のことをよく知っていて
でも結構冷静に見るんだから
どうか私に大した問題はないんだ
もしあるならば言うでしょうと
私はこんなにゴチャゴチャ心配しているのに
よくわかってるのに えらい冷静ではないかと
ということは 別に大したことはないんだということなんです
ですから 本当の冷静さの場合はそういうふうになります
次にある人が困っていて
自分が解決法を知っていた場合
ある人が困っている 自分が解決を知っている
自分が教えてあげるのが良い場合もある
自分が自分以外の誰かが教えてあげるのが良い場合
知っていたら教えてくださいと言われてからの方が良い場合
その人が自分で頑張ればなんとか解決できて
その方が良い場合など
いろいろな場合があると思います
その人の自由を保障して放っておいてあげるのはなかなか難しいのです
それはね あんまり私が説明することっていうことでもないんですけどもね
それは TPO だからね
教えてあげるか教えてあげないか
それはそのその TPO のことですよ
そんなに難しくはないんです
人が困っていて どうするべきかと
その場でその場で決めるもんですから
だから優しさが必要なんで
慈悲が必要ですよ 次に専門の質問ですから
それは置いといて  公平というのは難しいと
ということ質問ですね
公平と頑張っても 誰かの味方になってしまうこともあるし
贔屓になったりすることもありますと
まあ公平って何ですかね
それはどういうことかというと
Aさんが意見を持っていて
B さんも違う意見が持っていて
あなたはどちらに手を挙げますかと聞くと困るでしょ
例えば A さんがまあ 何か意見を言おう
今日はご飯食べましょうと
B さんが 今日は何も食べないでいましょうと
これはどちらでもすごい説得力があって
説得力があって喋ると
これお互い正反対だから
3人目に聞く どちらにすればいいんでしょうかと
どうすればいいんですか？その場合
そこで公平って何ですかね
だから そういう風にいろんな意見がある時
公平っていうのはやっぱりもう成り立たないんですよ
結局は なぜかというと
意見だからね どうったことないんですよ
主観だからね 意見が分かれたっていうことは
もうそれで終わりなんです
正しいんだったら分かれないんですよ
答えは一つですから どんなことにしたってものに
だからそちらで一つの人の立場をとるということは
もうとっくに公平じゃないんです
だから公平っていうのは
やっぱりまあそこら辺のデータを客観的に見ることなんですよ
客観的に見た上で その結果は食べることだったらもうしょうがない
その人の肩を取ったわけじゃないんです
客観的にデータ取ったところで
やっぱり今日食べない方がいいということになったならば
もうしょうがない じゃあ食べないことにするぞと
それであなた あの人の味方を取ったんだよと言ったっても
その人が間違いであってね
そういうふうに公平になり立つんです
公平っていうのは真理
事実なんです 事実以外のものは何一つも公平ではありません
読めない 加えてかな 育てればいけばいいかというね
それにも説明します だから差別したりというのは
差別はもう必要なことで
差別感は良くないし 差別感で判断は間違うし
ですから 日常生活で我々はただ見るだけで
明確に区別するだけで
分別するだけで生きてみれば
それが訓練なんですよ
なぜかというと 人間というのは感情の塊だから
無知の塊だから もう金かなかなかいつでも出るんですよ
だから結構気をつけて頑張らないと
しかし 頑張っていくと
感情の代わりに智慧の喜びが入り込むんですよ
智慧の喜びで入れ替えれば
もう全部きれいさっぱり消えます
次にあるのはこの専門的なことで
ウペッカーっていうのは慈悲喜捨の4番目なんです
慈悲はメッターで 悲はカルナーで
打てますか？で もうスライドなくても他のプログラムででもいいでしょうか
メッタ MET  まあそのうち出ますと思います
もちろん えーと メッタカルナムディタウペッカーという
この慈悲の瞑想では4段階あります
4番目はウペッカーなんです
それは漢文でも捨というふうな感じで訳していますけど
なんで捨になったかとわからないんだけど
でもよくよく考えてみると
捨も決して悪い感じでもないんですよ
だから 遠い昔のね ものすごい鋭く
この仏教を勉強した ものすごい鋭い人々が漢文に訳したんだから
これはこの見ては捨てるなんですよ
取らないということで
それで捨てるということにしている可能性はあります
そこで我々何もわからなくて
捨てる 捨てる なんで残酷やと思っちゃうんですけどね
特に生命に対してね まあ捨てるって何なのかと
これでこの慈悲の瞑想のウペッカーは何ですか？と
慈悲の瞑想 瞑想でどのようにこの沈着
冷静 沈着 冷静育てればよろしいかと
そこでこの方 テキストを読んでみると
素性は自分の業によって生きているものやというふうに観察するっていうふうに書いているんですけど
わからないんだ それは
この 1番目 メッタはわかりやすい
いう意味は友情なんです
わかりやすい  2番目はカルナ
憐れみなんですね 苦しんでいる人々は
どうか早く苦しみをなくしてほしいと思うことは憐れみなんですね
ムディタっていうのは喜びなんですよ
それはわかりやすい みんなうまくいっていると
ああ よかったよかったと握手することなんですよ
みんなの喜びを自分の喜びのように感じる
小さな子供はお母さんと楽しく楽しく遊んでいると
ああ よかったよかったと
お母さんも楽しくて 子供さんも楽しくて
ああ よかったと 自分も楽しむんです
人の楽しむ それは 3番目
ウペッカーは難しい 捨てることじゃないんです
見殺しにすることじゃないんです
生命のこと これが智慧につながるんですよ
だからはっきり言えば
仏教徒でないと仏教のとってがないんだから
仏教を理解して納得している人でないと
この瞑想はできないんです
...これが この一切の生命は平等である
ただ単にこの地球で集めた人はそれぞれ上下いろいろ性別
性別やらいろいろあるかもしれませんだけど
結局は皆平等であると
仏教は輪廻ということを教えているんです
だから 無限の過去から
生まれて死んで 生まれて死んで
生まれて死んでくるんですよ
無限の過去から生まれて死んでくるんだから
犬にもなるわ 猫にもなるわ
ミミズにもなるわ 神にもなるわ
地獄にも行くわ また人間にも戻るわ
人間に戻ったところで
金持ちにも生まれるわ
貧乏でも生まれるわ 健常者でも生まれるわ
障害者でも生まれるわと
もう無限から来るんだからね
それまた また知らない無限まで続いてしまいます
悟らない限りは そうすると
誰が偉くて誰が偉くないんですかね
みんな同じでしょ たまたま億万長者がいたっても
たまたまっていうわけじゃなくて
その人はそうなって生まれただけであって
次はどんな風な回転するかわからない
自分がすごいどん底貧乏であろうとも
輪廻から見れば誰でも距離が同じだから
だから冷静に見られる
悔しいと あの人は金持ちで
私は貧乏でとかね あの人と私は同じ勉強をして同じ学位を取ってるんですけど
あの人はいい仕事をして
私に仕事はない なんて悔しいやと
なんて不公平な世界だ
そういうことはなく まあそんなもんだよという世の中っていうのは
それで そのその人が今自分の業で生きているんだと
だから 金持ちになる業に当たったら金持ちになる
障害者になる業に当たったら障害者になるだけで
そこはここで死んじゃったら
それはそれで終わり 次に生まれる時はどんな業に当たるかわからない
そういうことで どんな人でも自分のものとして業を持ってるんだからっていうことで
で 冷静さを育てる どんな生命見たっても
だから すべての生命は生命として平等であるということを観察することなんです
それをやりやすくするために
業のことを考えなさいとか何とか言ってるんです
で もう一つウペッカーがあります
まあつあります 一つはこの
まあ体の感覚 苦しいっていう感覚がありますね
ドッカの感覚 楽しいという感覚がありますね
体に これはスカと言うんですね
スカ ドッカ ウペッカーという 3つあるんです
言ってますか？ スカ  SUKH
ドッカ KKHです  ドッカはまあ DUKH
スカはSUKH それでウペッカー
こういう 3つある これは感覚なんですよ
で スッカっていうのは楽な感覚
ドッカっていうのは苦しみの感覚
痛いとかね だからスッカっていうのは気持ちいいとかね
ドッカはもう痛い 気持ち悪いっていう感覚
ウペッカーっていうのはどちらでも入らないという意味
だから日本訳する場合は不苦不楽というふうに訳するんですね
スッカは楽 ドッカは苦
ウペッカは不苦不楽 苦しみでもなく楽しみでもない感覚と
それが単なる感覚で 今日のテーマでも何でもないんで
そんなのは別にどうったことはない
体の感覚だから 勉強の課題になるものではない
でもう一つウペッカーがあります
私は説明したかったのは
そのウペッカなんです
慈悲喜捨のあったウペッカーでもないんです
それは聞いたことはないと思いますから
私がします で これの専門用語はサンカールペッカーニャーナなんですね
で ニャーナは知恵 これはサンカーラウペッカーである
サンカーラに対してウペッカーという智慧なんです
これは私はもうほとんど使わないと
これはもう一般仏教用語でもなかなか我々出さない大事な専門用語の一つなんです
サンカーラっていうのは
すべての諸々 物事のこと
現象のこと それについて沈着冷静でいるという智慧です
だから沈着冷静っていうのは智慧なんです
これは育てなくちゃいけないんですよ
なんでそんなに大事なことを我々言わないかと
いうと これをヴィパッサナー実践する人々は
まあじわじわと進んでいくんですよ
じわじわと進んでいって
もうもう悟りのそこそこに行くと
悟れる次の下にあるのはこの智慧なんです
この智慧が現れて もうまたうろうろ瞑想していると
ボーンと悟りが開くんです
だから これを前もって言ったらダメなんです
もう知られてますから
どのみんなのことはね
確実に私を誤魔化そうと
騙そうと踏ん張るんですよ
で これは腹が立つんだからね
私のかなりのことを言うんです
その時は で 騙そうとしたところ
騙されなかったら 向こうはもうもうまた腹が立っても修行しないことにする
騙せません 仏教の世界では
だからウペッカーで見てみると
もう全部見られていますよ
だからこれはだいたい言わない
私だけではなくて もう誰でも言わない
あの 正式的なお坊さんたち
出家者たちは指導する場合はこれは言わない
それだけまだありますよ
ウペッカーにアナが生まれたら
もう悟りまでまたいくつかありますけど
それはもうそんなにタンタンタンと進めるもので
ここまではもうかなり時間をかけてゆっくりゆっくり至っていかなくちゃいけない
だから行 一切行と専門用語で言えばね
すべての物事は 無常である
瞬間で変わる だから客観的に見てみると
瞬間瞬間 細事に何にも変わるでしょ
人を見て その人はすごく嫌な顔をしていると
この人は性格悪いと決められますかね
その瞬間に嫌な顔をして
またこちら笑っちゃうと
向こう嫌な顔を消しちゃって笑ってくれる
だから何者かわからないでしょうに
誰もわからない 無常だから
その同じ人がある人にすごい不親切にする
それを見たら不親切な人やと決められません
その条件で不親切だけ
別な条件でまたすごい親切で
だからどんなものでもその瞬間だけのコマなんです
それをヴィパッサナー実践でよく理解するんですよ
そうすると何も捉えられない人を見ても判断できなくなる
その人はいい人か悪い人か何だか分からなくなる
その場でその場で変わるんですから
花見ても綺麗かどうかもうわからなくなる
その条件で綺麗に見える
別な条件で綺麗に見えない
ゴミでも見える 花は確実に綺麗と言ったっても
もうもうあっちこち取って
もうゴミ箱に入れちゃうと確実に綺麗に見えないでしょうに
ゴミで見えるんだから
だからゴミ箱の花を見る時の感覚と感覚と
そろそろ花が咲くでしょ
木でいろんなところである花が見る時の感覚は違うんですよ
だから その場でその場で
すべての物事は瞬間瞬間で変わるんだそうという無常と空
空しいと それから実体がないと
やっぱりすべてのものは無常であって
苦であって無我であるとわかったところで
もうどうにもならん サティができなくなる
もうどこまで観察すればいいかと
もうすぐ変わるんだからと
もうやりきれん状態になる
その瞬間で まあ冷静になろうではないかという風になるんですよ
それは自分の意思でなるものじゃない
自然になるんです それがサンカールペッカニャーナと言うんです
だから今日説明は 話は
このサンカールペッカニャーナの世界なんで説明できたのは
それはどうやって我々はゆっくりと順番で育てるのかと
だから私は最初からもう生まれつきじゃないんだと
これが智慧だよと これからだよと
沈着冷静な人間になるのは
なり始めた瞬間から幸福になります
感情を捨てて 差別感を捨て
捨てて 明確な区別差別で生きてみる
それで智慧が出てくる
どんどん知る世界はどんどん増える
それで智慧が向上する
智慧が向上すればするほどもう落ち着いていく
それでこの智慧が出てきて
次の完全たる自由っていうものが現れてきます
そういうことで 頑張っていただきたいことです
これが幸福の道なんです
この智慧が仏教では幸福と定義するんです
まあまあ これ次のステップなんですけど
それで全て捨てた状態が幸福と言いますけどね
ほんのちょっとだけでもとらわれないことが幸福なんです
そういうことで 今日の話は一応終了させていただきます
やっぱりいかがいかがでしたでしょうか
なんか幸福の道はどうだったというような感じで
皆さん一緒にチャレンジを
それでは質問があれば
あの 最初に日本語の訳がないっていう話だったんですけど
今までの話を聞いて あの
客観視するっていうのはどうかなと思ったんですけど
どうなんです  ね それも一応使ってはいましたけどもね
いろんなところで 客観視ですね
やっぱりウペッカーっていうのはね
うん そういうその言葉はいいと思います
はい それともう一つ あの認識する
しなきゃ知ることはできないっていうのがあったんですけども
私は認識するっていうことと
知ることを同一と思ってたんですけど
何か違う何か意図があるのかなと
そんなないんです そんなことしょうがないんです
同じというふうに考えていていいです
ありがとうございます
あ どうも 質問あるんですけども
まあ沈着冷静なところを育てるためにですね
今観察してるということなんですけど
瞬間の瞬間を観察していく場合だとね
とにかく忍耐という概念がなくて
精進するとか努力するという概念になると思うんですけども
その耐え忍ぶという概念はなくて
その時その時見てみるだけという
そういうふうじゃないかなと思うんですね
そうすると その立派な人が全部出てきます
そういった意味はもう忍耐という言葉はないというふうに理解して
だから完全なる平安でいるんだから
別に忍耐とそんなのはないんですよ
いいポイントだと思います
この我々はどこで忍耐するか
どこで頑張るかというと
これ感情が出てくるんだから
これ感情の塊 感情でできている人が
目も耳も鼻も何だかんだも感情で構成していて
感情なきになしにして見るっていうことがかなりきついんですよ
我々にとっては花だと見るよりは
なんてきれいな花だと見るのは楽ですよ
人のことを人ですと冷静に見るよりは
嫌な人だなと見るのは楽なんですよ
いろんな雑音が入ると
音と見るよりはうるさいと見るのは楽なんですよ
もう感情しか持ってないんだから
そこで忍耐 精進 努力という言葉が成り立つんです
だから感情がなくないとなにに努力するんですか？ただ見ればいいんだから
だから修行を我々指導するときでも
このあまり難しくは言ってないんです
すごい楽に ただ淡々と見てください
それで終わりと 淡々と見るだけで十分ですよ
淡々と見てくれない人が
頑固な人にとってはきついんで
修行は だから決して仏道は苦行ではありません
すごい安楽道で ものすごい楽しく修行できるんです
ブッダの瞑想っていうのは全くも単純で簡単で
まあ精進しなさいって言うんですけど
何に精進するんでしょうか？と聞きたいぐらいなんです
簡単ではないかと だからもう感情だけね
割り込まないんだったらもう OK ですよ
感情っていうのはかなり質が悪くて
結構悪く割り込む 割り込んじゃうと
みんな瞑想をやめて元に戻しちゃうんですね
怒らないより怒ること楽でしょうしね
それは私たちの無知の問題で
見てはいるが見ていない
生きてはいるようですが
本当は生きてない状態でいるんだからね
で まあ結構実践して 訓練して磨かないと自分をね
できないことです ですから
人によって忍耐 努力 励む
捨てもという言葉成り立ちます
人によって成り立たない
お釈迦様の話を聞いて
瞬時に悟った人もいるんだから成り立たないんですよ
その人に励む 捨ても努力するという
何十年も徹夜して修行するお坊さんたちもいました
結構忍耐でしょ それは人によります
感情に振り回されることを怠けというんです
楽だから 怒るのは簡単でしょ
それから私たちは心でバイアスを持っていると
それで見るのは楽ですよ
例えば怒りのバイアスを持っている
そうすると何でも批判的に見えちゃう
批判したくなる 馬鹿にしたくなる
コケにしたくなる それがもう慣れちゃったもんで楽なんです
それで欲のバイアスが入る
何でも褒めたくなる ああ
綺麗 ああ美しいとかね
そういう風に言いたくなる
そうすると その人にはその生き方が楽なんですよ
それで楽な生き方すると怠けというんです
客観的に客観視することは
その人にとっては努力なんです
素直に話を聞いて その瞬間で客観視すると
もうすごい短い時間で悟り開けます
その人には別に何に努力するんでしょうかと
というのなんですね 当たった解説します
うん すいません 画家がいまして
画家がですね 絵を描くと
その時にはこう 感情かこう
痛かったりとかいろいろ言って
その描いて それでその現れが結果的には個性が豊かだと言ったりすると思うんですけども
その時にその芸術家なんかは
これ感情というのは感情ではない
それ感情ですよ 理性ではないんだからね
でも問題は だから芸術世界は仏教ではやらんだから
あの 例えば修行する場合は
この全部カットしなさいと
音楽 踊り お化粧 全部カットしなさいと言ってるし
で 出家するともうこれはもう断然禁止ですからね
演奏やらもうやってはいけないと
で なぜならばそれは感情ということになるし
それで芸術家たちが作る感情っていうのは
ほんのわずかしかない
欲か怒りか あるいはぐちゃぐちゃ無知かとかね
で あの あそこどこでしたっけ？パーリとバリ島のね
ウブッドという村がありますね
そちらで芸術村でしょうしね
麻薬はあるわ そんなの使いたい放題使って
もうサイケデリックの絵を描いたりとかね
なんで麻薬まで使うこと？もう表せる感情がないんですごい乏しい
もう欲か怒りでしょ サイケデリックの場合はもう無知
何やと ある人 その猫の絵を見たんですよ
もうもうむちゃくちゃ猫の一かけらもないんです
もうものすごい精密に線をもう何万線
盆栽も描いてるんです
描いて描いて描いて 目のところでももうむちゃくちゃもう何万千線
すごい繊細に描いてますよ
もう確かに優秀な芸術家だからね
猫はどこにいるかと どこにもいない
しかし サイケデリックな状態で猫を見たら
そうやってもうド派手なこと見えたでしょう
それがすごいお金払ってみんな買っている
買ってる人の家で見たんですけどね
あれ見たらえらい苦しいやと思ったんです
本人が高いお金で買ったんだから何も言わなかったんですけどね
これはもうちょっと精神的な異常じゃないか
この人 それは実はそうです
この芸術的な世界では
こういうこういうことで
こういうものが出来上がりますよと言われちゃったんですけども
そうですね こちらもそれを見ただけで分かったんだからね
だから芸術家もかなり苦しんでるんですよ
この次の作品をしようかと
表せる感情がないんです
今思い出した例なんですけど
またおしんというですけど
私は日本に来る時にやっていたんですね
しかし それは世界的に世界で放送したんです
だからタイ語をしゃべるお神もいるわ
英語をしゃべるお神もいるわ
フランス語をしゃべるお神がいるわ
誰でもあれはものすごいと見る
前のね アメリカの大統領も二人も見てね
ということは みんなに認められるすごい作品でしょ
では 同じ作品もう一つ作ってくださいと
まだまだすごいいろんなドラマ書いてるで
その本人が くっだらないんですよ
書いてるの 同じ人が書いたかと
思うほど だから結局表せる感情っていうのはそれしかない
とにかく NHK の朝のドラマっていうのは全く一つテーマでしょ
ずっと だから同じテーマで毎年毎年書けるものはないんですよ
もう だから結構苦しいも
だから感情を表すって言ったっても
えらい苦労してるだけなんですよ
それでもし客観視すれば芸術作品できないかというと違うんです
いくらでもできるんです
相手にあなたどんなことを表してほしい
あ そう はい わかりました
作品を作りますと だからインスピレーションというのは無限に出てくるんです
客観視すれば だからお釈迦様は音楽なんかに反対なんですけど
音楽でも心を綺麗にする感情を表せますよ
慈しみ 平和 平等 というものを音楽で表れます
しかし 一つも別れの歌
船と港と酒場と  それは演歌で
それでもそれよりひどいんですね
若者の歌っていうのは
それも全部別れの歌で品がなくて
もうなんて言います 作詞ですか
それもろくなものはなくて
たまたますごい美しい歌も出てくるでしょ
たまたま 言葉でも綺麗で
川の流れのように なんとか何とかとかね
そういう いい歌もね 出てきたりするし
インスピレーション インスピレーションですね
インスピレーションでしょ
インスピレーションは感情では出てこないんです
ストップしちゃうんです
だから 感情で生活している人々は
もう結構普通の仕事をする人々はかなり苦しいんですよ
それで病気になる この間はマイケル・ジャクソンのなんか番組がありまして
こいつえらい病気だなと
ものすごくかわいそうやと思う
正真正銘 これがすごい病気だと
ちょっとしたことで興奮してしまう
もうどうにもならない
大人と付き合うことは全くできない
あの人の家でいっぱい子供たちとかいるんだからね
子供たちとすると いえ
何で泣く？それはこの人は私たちと同じ年だよと
だから一緒に遊んだりすることは簡単にできますよと
成長しない それ以上はね
本当は病院に運んでとことん治療させなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから別にその人は生まれつき病気ではなくて
本当に芸術家ですよ 抜群にその能力あります
あるんだけど それはもう感情を表す世界で使っているんだから
結局自分がもうなんて言いますか
自分で自分を燃やす準備になっているんですね
だからやっぱり客観視はね
すべての幸福の道なんですよ
それで 例えば自分の国がもうできた時から仏教の国で
かなり歴史が古いんだけど
記録されているちゃんと歴史っていうのは仏教と一緒に成り立っているもので
だから 2500 の歴史は全部仏教の歴史で
何の芸術もなかったんですかと
ちょっと生きていられないでしょうね
音楽もあるわ 踊りもあるわ
いろんなものあります
しかし それは全部 この何か尊いことを表現しようではないかと
それで使うんですよ 踊る時でもいろんな真理を語って踊る
例えば稲刈りする時の歌とかあります
稲刈りの踊りもあります
その時ももうすごい言葉は綺麗ですよ
昔の言葉だから なかなか今の現代人にわからないんですけど
本当に言葉綺麗ですよ
人生っていうのはね こういう風に苦しんでやるものだよとね
いくらなんでもね これで我々は業が悪いんだから
こういう風に苦しくて
稲を刈りて 籾をなんて言いますか
砕いて生活しなくちゃいけないんだと
まあそれでももう食べるものはいただいて
もうありがたいことですと
そうやってこの生きる苦しみを歌いながら
稲刈りをする それは昔はこれすごいきれいな祭りでしたから
稲刈りはね 稲刈りっていうのは仕事じゃない
昔は祭り それで村の人々
大体女の人々は大体そういう仕事をするんだから
男たちも一生懸命仕事をするし
それでこの声がきれいな誰かが
男性か女性かがいて どこかで座って
なんかそれなりの簡単な何か楽器みたいなものを
あのチェンチェンと鳴らすものを何か一つ二つで歌うんですよ
本人が 1番目の 1番目を歌ったら
みんな合唱で同じことを繰り返して歌う
それでまた歌うと終わりまでやるんです
だから稲刈りてるか何か歌って踊ってるかどっちだかわからないというかね
で 終わりまで それであの牛で稲から籾を取るでしょ
それは徹夜して牛たちがやるんですよ
それにまた別な歌があるんです
その時は男性だけなんですけど
で それぞれいろいろ それでも最初にも最初のご飯を取ってから
もうお釈迦様の部分やらもう神様の部分やら全部分けて
で そういうものをまた料理して
お寺に持ってくるとかあります
それまたお祭りで だから人生はすごい楽しんでたんですよ
だから娯楽と仕事っていうのは一緒なんですね
だから別に娯楽がない
それで観光の人々が行ったら
なんだつまらない国ではないか
何も遊ぶところはないんだと
それが我々嫌なんです
踊る いわゆる溺れた遊び方をね
カジノがあったり 売春宿があったりとか
嫌なんです なんで必要かと
楽しいんだから 生きることはね
それでいっぱい歌があるわ
いろんな作品もあるわ
絵も描くわ お寺で今はほとんどボロボロな
行ってみたらもう壁いっぱい絵を描いてるんだからね
壁のところじゃなく 天井も残しようところがなし
全部絵を描く それでお金がお金ね
ゆっくりと描きます 信者さんにお金がちょっと入ったら
それは寄付して それでほんのちょっと描いて
その寺の仕事をする人々もそれはよくわかっていて
一応契約を書いても これは十年で終わるか
六年八年よくわかったもんじゃない
向こうもたまたま寺に来て
もう三ヶ月間とかね 寺に泊まって
ご飯作って食べて 何か壁の絵を描いて
それでお坊さんの持ってるお金が終わっちゃったら
もう全部道具持って他のお寺に行くんです
そこでまた絵を描いていて
そこでその信者さんからあしたお金が終わっちゃうで
またそれ道具を売って
また別のお寺に行く それです
本人には一年中仕事があります
そこでまた一年 二年でまたちょっとちょっとちょっとね
十円とか五十円とかお金集めて
またいくらかなったら
またその人はその時ちょうどうまい具合に来るんですね
そういう風に作ったりして
やっぱり貧しいっていうのは問題にしない
生活することは苦しいと全然問題にしない
何でも楽しく笑いながらやっている
だから笑うということは
まああの国だったらものすごい普通で
いつでもなんかちょっと何か
何かちょっと違うことを言って人を笑わせないと格好悪いんですよ
だから私にしても 性格的には日本語になっちゃったんだから
もうものすごいハンディなんですよ
自分の言葉になると 自分でも知らない
何言うかと いろんなことを言う
だから簡単に楽で難しい説法でもできます
別にもう何でも言うんだからね
だからこの笑い芸人がだからいないんです
みんな笑ってるんだから
普通に そういうことだから
この芸術っていうのは人を楽しませる
喜ばせることだから それを見事に仏教の世界やってあげるんです
今 西洋的な芸術家っていうのは
もうただの欲の世界で
欲を表すを表現しようということだったら
感情っていうのはほんの狭いんだからね
欲の感情より慈しみの感情っていうのはどれほど広いかと
この人こと知らないでしょうに
欲っていうのは異性に対しての欲でしょうに
だから狭いというと あまりにも信じられない
こんな狭さでよく生きてるんだよ
これ慈しみに変わっちゃうと
広い広いというもうあまりにも無限大に広いでしょうに
それを表したらどうですかと
だからこの即席の道が間違ってるは明らかに苦しみの道なんです
それで音楽もできる すごい簡単にインスピレーションが出てくる
喜びの音楽っていうのは
それで日本でよく聞くドイツの喜びの音楽
私の喜びで聞こえない
あれは叫びだといつでも思うんですよ
喜びじゃないんだと 作った本人も喜んでやったわけじゃないんだから
あまりにも苦しいことことで
まあ才能あったんだからね
まあまあやったんであって
で 本当の音楽っていうのは
今日本でもいろんな音楽家が言うでしょ
もう売れる歌っていうのは
もうなんとなく出来上がっちゃうもんだよと
それで考えて作るものはなかなか売れない
人気がないということは
本人がすごくリラックスしてなんかボケている時はなんとなく曲が浮かんじゃう
それがすぐもう人気が出てきて
もう売れてしまう だからリラックスして
明らかな心で 慈しみが育っていると
いくらでもインスピレーションというのはもう腐るほどあるということなんです
お釈迦様の前でも歌ったことがありますね
あの あの あの神様のね
天国の帝釈天の あの 音楽を奏でる神様が
いわゆる音楽隊の隊長なんですよ
だから天国でしょうに
そこでお釈迦様に会って帝釈天も会いたがっているんだよと
言っても 帝釈天がちょっとサボっちゃって
長い間お釈迦様に挨拶しに来るのはなんかちょっと顔を合わせなくて
まあ君は行って最終にちょっと話つけてくれと
で 音楽家だからね いつでもどんな人にもね
会うこと仕事だから わかりましたと言ってお釈迦様にやったんですけど
この人そのことを言わないで
お釈迦様の前で演奏するんですよ
その歌もパーリ語であります
そういうのもとでとんでもない歌を歌ったんじゃけどね
で 結局恋の歌なんですね
その辺もお釈迦様のように恋の歌
別にお釈迦様もずっと終わりまで聞いていたんです
なかなかいい作品だよと
演奏もよく合ってるんだよと
で 褒めてくれたところで
まあ実はもう一つ用事があって来たんだよということで
もう帝釈天が会いたがってるんだよと
まあいいよ 呼びなさいということで呼んで
そこで別な説法になります
だから別に仏教はもうそんな反対だ
嫌いだということではなくて
苦しむなよと 確かに芸術家の世界ではね
まあみんな苦しんでいることだけは確かなんです
表現だから この美術館やらね
行ったら何を見てもなんだこれ
なんだこれとね 私は個人的にはそう思っちゃうんですね
これ美じゃなくて苦でしょうと
苦しむんだったらいくらでも苦しめますから
なんでお金払って美術館に行って
またさらに苦しむんですかね
そこで欲を表現する 欲と違って何か愛情を表現すると
なんとか このもう女の人が子供を抱っこしているようなぐらいのものなんですね
やっぱりそれでも母と子の執着的な愛しか表現できないんですよ
もし慈しみだったら どんな子も子供だよと
どんな母も母だよというものすごい広い感情が出てくるんですよ
それが表現できればいかにすごいかと
だから仏教はすごい芸術の世界ですよ
仏像も作っているわ もう中央アジアがただ歩いただけで
もう全部いまだに残っている
洞窟を掘ったらもう砂漠でしょ
その中にもものすごい世界を作る
教えは無常である ドッカであるとか
何も頼るものは何一つこの世の中でないという教えなんですけど
それから出てくる智慧で
もうすごく楽しくいるんです
だから中央アジアのね
お坊たちがただ自分の個人の個室でしょ
個室で寝て瞑想するだけ
これ部屋を見ると もう
作るは作るは 描くはもうキリがなく作るは
私はその 何て言いますかね
あの性格っていうのはすごく楽しくて
穏やかで気楽で それはもうイスラム教に全部潰されて壊されちゃったんですけど
でも残っているさん 史跡は跡だけでも我々をいまだに喜ばせてくれる
あのタリバンが壊したあの仏像も
あの顔なんかあったらどれほど迫力あるすごい作品かと
だから人間の喜びを壊しちゃって
もうずっと苦しんでるんですね
あの人々も いつでもどこを見てなんか不幸
油田があっても不幸 どうにもならん
自分の息子でも信頼できん
かわいそうですけどね
そういうことで 仏教の世界で
この客観視することで
限りなく問題にも答えが出てくる
インスピレーションが限りなく出てくるんだということ
それは一応話の内容で入れてあったんですけど
はい また  じゃあこの辺で
ちょっと今日も時間でしたので
じゃあレコードの方でお話していただいて
ありがとうございました
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬愛し
戒を守り 義の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳
先祖 祖国 両親 親族 恩師をはじめとし
一切の親しい人々に回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての親しい人が幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱に達されますように
サンヴェーティヨ ヴィワッジャントゥ サッバローゴ ヴィナッサトゥ
マーテー バワットゥ アンタラーヨ スキーディーガー ユコー バワ
バワトゥ サッバ マングラッン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバ ブンターヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマーヌバ
ーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ
サダー ソッティー バワントゥ テ アビワダンナ シーリッサ ニッチャン ワンダパジャイノ
チャッターロー ダンマー ワッダンティー アユワッノー スカン バラン アユーラーローギヤ サンプッティー サンガ サンプッティー メーウェーチャ
アトー ニンバーナ サンプッティー ミナーテー サミッジョトゥ
[鐘の音] では ご歓談終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]